esta vez vamos a practicar contando
dinero veamos que tenemos aquí tengo
seis monedas si en este ejemplo vamos a
trabajar con monedas mexicanas esta
moneda que está aquí es una moneda de 20
pesos
la siguiente también es una moneda de 20
pesos bueno a ella nada más le voy a
poner el valor 20 y la siguiente vez es
una moneda idéntica también de 20 pesos
así que estas tres monedas que están
aquí
suman 60 pesos si mira es 20 20 40 20 60
60 pesos
muy bien la siguiente moneda es una
moneda de 5 pesos esta de aquí es una
moneda de 5 pesos la siguiente moneda
también es una moneda de 5 pesos así que
aquí pondré un 5
estas dos monedas suman cinco y cinco
diez son diez
finalmente tengo una moneda de un peso
está que está aquí tiene el valor de un
peso ahora veamos cuál es el valor que
suman todas estas monedas pues aquí
tengo 60 pesos más 10 son 70 más 171
quiere decir que todas estas monedas que
están aquí suman 71 pesos muy bien pero
tal vez estés pensando que hacer la
cuenta en la cabeza como hicimos puede
ser complicado así que vamos a hacerlo
de otra manera vamos a poner el valor de
cada una de ellas es decir tengo tres
monedas de 20 pesos 123 después tengo
dos monedas de 5 pesos
2 y finalmente tengo la moneda de un
peso
ahora vamos a sumar las todas
entonces aquí tengo 00 es 00 es 0 555 es
10 10 111 el 11 tiene una unidad y una
decena la cual escribo aquí ahora tengo
uno más dos es 312 5 más 12 77 decenas
muy bien
ahora hagamos otro ejemplo veamos que
tenemos aquí abajo
muy bien esta vez tengo 123456789
monedas podemos observar que la primera
es una moneda de 20 pesos muy bien
es una moneda igual que el ejemplo
anterior después podemos observar que
ahora tenemos dos monedas que no
conocíamos son nuevas en este ejercicio
pero cada una es una moneda de 10 pesos
así que pongo una y otra moneda de 10
pesos las siguientes monedas son dos
monedas de cinco pesos estas ya las
conocíamos una dos muy bien
dos monedas de cinco pesos y finalmente
tenemos cuatro monedas de un peso una
dos tres cuatro que vamos a escribir una
dos tres cuatro
pero aquí podríamos escribir un cuatro
para representar las cuatro monedas de
un peso a ver vamos a escribirlas
aquí pongo un 4 y corresponde a 1 2 3 4
monedas de un peso
ahora vamos a sumar las todas
tengo 0000 es 05 55 es 10 414
14 tiene cuatro unidades y una decena
que escribo aquí ahora 12 es 3 1 4155
decenas o sea 54 y observemos algo
interesante en este segundo ejemplo
todas las monedas suman 54 pesos y aquí
arriba
- monedas suman en total 71 pesos
eso es lo que tenemos
pero podemos observar que en el primer
ejemplo tenemos más monedas de 20 pesos
tenemos 3 monedas cada una de estas
monedas de 20 pesos representa el valor
de 20 monedas de un peso por lo que el
valor total es mayor